a breakfast to really set you up for the
day easy homemade spicy fake beans with
deliciously light potato cakes
[Music]
the first big thing
that i remember as a kid was
and beans
so this is like a little rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta ernie come on
disappear
go and chase some mice now panel get
nice and hot i'm gonna turn these beans
into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly
season that it's cured so it doesn't
need that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how the individual tastes
of baked beans they're somewhat bland so
i always like to make them a little bit
more spicy
so
a nice finely chopped chili
with the seeds
chili in
now a little bit of garlic
crushed
phenomenal
[Music]
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chili
and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards
slice across and then cut down to simply
dice
bacon onion chilli garlic
that flavor all contained in that little
pan
once you've sweated the onion off
a little bit of sugar in there
the brown sugar will start to caramelize
darken
and enrich as well at the same time
that looks beautiful
now
a couple of tablespoons of cider vinegar
delays the pan it's got that really nice
powerful kick to it now spice that up
with one of my favorite seasonings
worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your
passata puree tomatoes
turn that down
simmer the sauce to reduce
then add in the classic baked bean
harrico beans
you can buy haircut beans dried or
canned they are packed with protein and
have a lovely soft texture
turn down the heat
and let the beans absorb
all that beautiful spicy tomato sauce
and just let that simmer now
five or six minutes now for my potato
cakes they're a fantastic way to use
leftover boiled potatoes and are so easy
to make
i'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour and butter to the mash
that gives it that nice sort of
cakey texture and it goes from this
leftover ball potato
to this nice light
flowery
potato heaven take a nice
spoon of potato lightly flour your board
we're gonna fry these
crisp
on the outside and just
nice and fluffy in the center
now
get your pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil
into the pan
now put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up by the time
it goes into the center
it's almost sort of nut brown
gently
turn them over
love that nice
light crisp
they look beautiful
now take them out
potato cake in the middle
and a nice
beautiful
spoon
of beans
growing up with beans on toast as a
treat
still to this day after all those years
has not changed my love or attitude for
beans
especially cooked like that
[Music]
my smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and creamy potato cakes comfort
and satisfaction on a plate
[Music]
family favorite boiled eggs with a
soldier that will make your taste buds
stand to attention
there's something quite nostalgic about
a bald egg it's something that's never
lost it's magic when you slice that top
off and dunk that soldier into the yolk
you can't mess with a deliciously runny
yolk but this is what i like to dunk in
it an anchovy soldier anchovies
interpersonal water no salt naturally
yeah anchovies are very salty so just a
touch of pepper
rich in omega-3s the amazing tinned
anchovy is a natural flavor enhancer and
i use it to pepper many a savory dish
from roast lamb to the humble toasted
soldier
grind them
to a really nice smooth paste the smell
of that is almost like being at the
seaside now get your soft butter
and just put half the butter in first 50
50 is the way 50 percent anchovy pretend
butter that way got that real nice salty
creaminess mix that up
that's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish i'm in heaven
the bread
this is a sourdough
delicious very crusty
take four nice slices
now get that pan nice and hot
a couple of tablespoons of that anchovy
oil into the pan and then get your bread
and lightly fry each side
the smell the anchovy oil is incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil
the secret of softly boiling an egg is
to place them into the water gently on a
spoon
in
and just tilt so they don't hit the
bottom nice
and light
up to the ball count to five
turn the gas down is it four and a half
minutes is it five minutes for a
softball day i've cooked thousands of
them and every time
it's four and a half minutes whilst
that's boiling
get your bread
and spread that on there that is
incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
hear that crunch
on
i'm sorry but i can't resist
oh my god
right
gas off
one
beauty in
two
i feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault and that little magic inside is
all yours
there's a great twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
perfectly soft boiled eggs with dressed
up anchovy butter soldiers
who would have thought that egg and
soldiers could be that delicious
[Music]
eggs bait in hash browns
the secret of a great hash brown
are the potatoes
i prefer using really nice waxy potatoes
they cook better but more importantly
hold themselves together
we're not gonna slice the onion all the
potatoes but we're actually gonna grate
them the potatoes get really nice and
crispy i mean seriously crispy now the
onion
that way you get that nice
balance of the onion flavor running
through
every little shard of potato
[Music]
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
and then squeeze
all that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze
out there
really important the more liquid you
remove the crispier your hash browns
will be
nice large pan put that on
once the pan is hot pour in a good glug
of olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms
how important it is to have your pan
nice and hot
so it seals
the grated potato onion together
so take the spoon
and just
pat it down
what we're trying to do now is get it
really nice and compact
going around the outside of the pan with
little flecks of butter you just slip
them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelised
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over
and then slide it back in
very quickly
you see the color
we've got on there now
got that nice
crispy texture
of the potato i'm going to use the hash
brown as a bed for my baked eggs
crack in your eggs nice and gently just
a little sprinkling of the cayenne
to make the eggs a little bit spicy then
into a preheated oven for six to eight
minutes meanwhile onto my bacon and i'm
giving it a classic american twist now
one thing i could never get my head
around when i first started eating lots
of american breakfast was the
sweetness from the bacon i've grown up
to love that combination of smoky sweet
flavors and it's so easy
pan on and simply heat olive oil brown
sugar salt and pepper and butter
bacon in and as it cooks it becomes
irresistibly caramelized and golden
brown toffee gas
and my glazed bacon
absolutely ready beautiful
now my hash browns and baked eggs are
ready
wow
look at that
beautiful
just
put your spatula underneath there
onto your plate
and that bacon
sets beauty on top of the baked eggs and
that hash brown underneath and
you can see why the best breakfasts in
the world are always in america
this is an all-american superhero offer
breakfast eggs bait in hash browns with
glazed bacon
[Music]
you